الا ليت الشباب يعود يوميا جمله التمني
شهيره هذا ربما تصبح واقعا قريبا في خطوه
طال انتظارها نحو شباب دائم نجاح دارس في
مجال عكس الشيخوخه حققه علماء من بوسطن في
عمليات على الفئران باستخدام تقنيات
التجديد الخلوي
بنت انسجه عضليه اكثر صحه وخلايا اكثر
شبابا
عمليه قابله للعكس ويمكن دفعها للامام
والخلف حسب الرغبه حسب الباحثين فالناس
استاذنا تحتوي على نسخه الاحتياطيه من
شبابنا يمكن تحفيزها عبر التجدد
ما هو ان هذه التقنيه تحدي بشكل كبير او
تحد من الامراض التقدم في السلك القلب
ما الذي حدث للفئران بالضبط تمكن العلماء
من تحديد عمري انسجه المخ والعينين
والعضلات والجلد والكلى لدى الفئران
وابتكر ديفيد سيكلر خبير مكافحه الشيخوخه
واستاذ علم الوراثه مزيجا لما حقنه في
الخلايا التالفه في عيون الفئران العمياء
وتم تغطيتها بالمضادات الحيويه النتائج
كانت مذهله فقد استعاده الفئران هو اعظم
مصاريفها ويعد ذلك الرجل الفريق خلايا
الدماء والعضلات والكلى واعادها الى
مستويات اصغر بكثير اليوم يحاول فريق
البحث هذا طريقه لتوصيل التبديل الجيني
بالتساوي لكل خليه وبالتالي تشديد شباب
الفقر دي اكمله وقد تمر عقود قبل ان تبدا
اي تجارب اكديكيه لمكافحه الشيخوخه على
البشر واذا كانت امنه وناجحه يتم توزيعها
الى الحجم المطلوب للموافقه الفيدراليه
[موسيقى]
ينضم ليله من ولايه كارولين الشماليه
الامريكيه دكتور فواز العنزي استشاري
امراض القلب والباطنيه وخبير فحوصات القلب
دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا من جديد
صباح العربيه هل بالفعل يمكن تحفيز الجسم
على العوده الى الشباب
صبحكم الله بالخير طبعا وارد هذا الامر
الجديد النتائج المذهله يعني والطريقه
الجديده مسبقا كانت جميع الابحاث تتكلم عن
التغير في الحمض النووي نفسه لكن هناك
عوامل اخرى مؤثره تسمى عوامل مساعده ما
يعرف بالاربيجينز هذه الدراسه ركزت على
الابجينز الابيجينز هو وظيفته ترتيب
النسيج الجيني تنشيط او تثبيطه او تغيير
حتى اماكن وجعل الخلايا تكون خلايا جلديه
او خلايا دماغيه الدراسه هذه ركزت على هذا
الامر واكتشفت انه تعب هذا الابجينز او
هلاك هذا الابجينز من اساسه تظهر عوامل
همم شيخوخه او ما يعرف به التغير اللي
يحدث عند كبار السن لكن النتائج الدراسه
لاذهلت وفعلا تقريبا اكثر من نصف اعضاء
جسم الفار رجعت للحاله الطبيعيه
يعني دكتور فواز هذه الدراسه يعني فعلا
مذهله لمن يقراها عنوان جدا جدا لفت مريض
لكنها طبقات على الفئران هل يمكن فعلا ان
تطبق وتتطابق 100% علينا نحن بشر
طبعا حقيقه الان تجرى الابحاث على الخلايا
البشريه ولكن ليس على البشر بشكل مباشر
يعني تم اخذ خلايا من جسم الانسان خلايا
الانسجه ووضح في اماكن مخصصه وعمل التجارب
عليها اعتقد الخطوه الجايه ليس الانسان بل
القرده ليوجد تشابه كثير في التركيب
الجيني للقرد وللانسان اذا كانت هناك
نتائج على القرده نتوقع ان نتائج تكون على
الانسان ولكن انتظر طيب من الناحيه الطبيه
العلميه المنطقيه يا دكتور هل تتوقع ان
يكون التغيير الى الشباب
على المظهر الخارجي يعني على الجلد فقط ام
على اعضاء حيويه في الجسم كالكلى الدماغ
القلب
الحقيقه في الدراسه هذه على الاقل على
الفئران يعني الكيلر رجعت للامور الطبيعيه
النظر رجع في الحدود الطبيعيه بعد مشاكل
القلب تم تحسينها اعتقد نعم قد يغير في
مسار بعض الامراض او يقلل من خطوره بعض
الامراض الشكل طيب دكتور فواز بعد الفئران
بعد الفئران وفي المستقبل القريب القرده
ونحن نتبع البشر هل فعلا يمكن ان نتوقع
نتخيل علاج يعيد شبابنا يوما ما هل هذا
حقيقي
معنى اتمنى هذا الشيء لكن اعتقد هاء
الاجابه على هذا السؤال جدا صعبه همم قد
نغير في مسار بعض الامراض قد نخفف من بعض
الامراض لكن الرجوع للشباب لا اعتقد هذا
الشيء هذه الامور خارج يعني قدره البشريه
وقد الله تعالى طيب دكتور لا خبرتك
بالموضوع هنتوقع ان يكون علاج الشيخوخه
ومكافحه الشيخوخه والعوده الى الشباب يؤخذ
على شكل عقار على شكل مضاد حيوي يعني كيف
تتصورون الموضوع
اعتقد نمو جسم الانسان يجب ان يمر في هذه
المراحل اعتقد نستطيع ان نغير من شكل
الجلد او ان يبقى الشعر يعني في اللون
الاسود لكن اعتقد عمر الانسان ومراحل تطور
الانسان منذ الولاده الى يوم الوفاه اعتقد
هذه يصعب همم التغير في انها تعتمد على
عده عوامل ولا اعتقد ان نستطيع ان ندخل في
هذا الامر وايضا الدخول في هذا الامر خطير
لان اليوم احنا نتعامل مع التركيب الجيني
نعرف الكثير وانا اجهل الكثير وقد تظهر
هناك امراض وطفرات جينيه
حتى التعامل معها تنتقل من جيلي الاخر
دكتور فواز
اليوم
حاول تقدم هذه الخدمه
مقال يوم بداوا منها اليوم طبعا هذا الامر
مقلق جدا هناك شركات فعلا استندت الى بعض
الابحاث وتم اخذها والصنع كثير من
الكريمات وصنع كثير من المواد وحتى اجراء
امور داخليه في العيادات اعتقد الى الان
الامر مبكر على هذا الامر وو- وفعلا هناك
اموال طائله بالمليارات قد تكون هي
الاموال بعد يعني الاموال الثانيه في
العالم اللي تصرف على هذا الامر طيب دكتور
يعني من الناحيه العلميه حتى نفهم منك
اكثر كخبير في هذا الشان ما دام انه هكذا
علاجاته تنطبق على الحيوانات لماذا ينتظر
تطبيقها على البشر ليتم التاكد من مدى
يعني فعاليتها
دي خطورتها الشديده انت اليوم تتعاملين مع
التركيب الجيني التركيب الجيني هي هيئه
معقده حتى اصعب الكمبيوترات لا يستطيع ان
يقرا كل التركيب الجيني ناخذ فقرات معينه
من الفار من من نسيج الجيني للفار ونتعامل
معها بشكل يدوي الامر جدا صعب يعني يحتاج
تحتاجين تحتاجين الى عمل يعني لا يكاد
يكون الدراسه هذه طولت ثلاث 13 سنه يعني
الموضوع مو بسيط يعني 13 سنه عشان يوصل
لهذه المرحله الدكتور فواز
دكتور فواز امس قرات بانه فيه 155 جين
جديد سيتطور مع تطور البشريه هل بالتالي
مثلا ابتكار مثل هكذا علاجات يمكن ان
تتوقف مع هذه الطفرات والتطورات الجينيه
لجسد الانسان
التوافق الجيني والتغير الجيني هو بشكل
يومي لكن هذا الاب يجي ينزل موجود في جسم
الانسان يعمل على ارجاع الجينات الى
امورها الطبيعيه احنا في جسمنا بشكل يومي
هناك ملايين الانقسامات للخلايا وتكون
خلايا جديده بشكل يومي تعطي من ضمنها
تركيب الجيني لكن اي خلل يحدث مثل التطور
الجيني الحديث تعمل يعمل جسم الانسان على
ارجاعه ولكن للاسف هناك امراض لا يستطيع
التحكم فيها يعني لذلك نبدا تظهر على جسم
الانسان العيوب الخلقيه او بعض امراض الدم
او بعض السرطانات نعم هناك امور لا لا
نستطيع التحكم امور اخرى دكتور كامراض
مزمنه كالقلب الكلى وما الى ذلك هل يمكن
ان تعالج ان تكون مبشره بعلاج همم من قبل
هذه التجارب
جدا بشكل واضح لا ننسى من فتره يعني حتى
عن طريق قناتكم تكلمنا عن التقنيه اللي
غيرت خليه جذعيه جلديه لخليه تفرز ماده
الانسولين لذلك للناس اللي عندهم امراض
السكر يعني زرعها في البنكرياس وبدات تنتج
ماده الانسولين نعم يستخدم في عده امور
خلايا كلويه خلايا القلب عندما يضعف القلب
نزرع الخلايا الجذعيه وتتحسن وظيفه القلب
نعم هناك استخدامات عده دكتور فؤاد في حال
تم تجربه هذا العلاج وتم توافقه على البشر
هل سينتهي دور اطباء التجميل
لا اعتقد ان الامر ليس فقط شكلي بل اعتقد
هو امر نفسي
ونرى ولكن لا اعتقد هذا الشيء نورنا دائما
بنصائح نقيمه شكرا دكتور فواز العنزي
استشار امراض القلب الواطيه والباطن وخبير
الفحوصات القلب شكرا دكتور نورتنا